Britney Spears is dancing around her
home with knives with big shark knives
she's denied it though
and said I started playing in the
kitchen with knives today don't worry
they're not real knives but I look at
those knives
they look pretty real they don't look
like plastic knives or anything to me so
I have to ask myself was it really a
good idea to free Britney
we up the free Brittany movement
was based on this idea that Brittany has
the right to Liberty just true we all we
all want Liberty Liberty is a good thing
but the reason the free Brittany
movement was wrong is because the free
Brittany movement presupposed a
definition of Liberty based on choice
not based on perfect willing and
understanding